hello my name is nicolina radulovic and
i am a staff scientist at university
health network in toronto canada
and for the past five years i have been
leading a next generation biobanking
facility princess margaret living
biobank and my experience lies in the
generation of patient-derived organ
remodels and today i would like to give
you an overview of what we have
accomplished and go over some lessons we
have learned along the way
so
this is an overview of presentation
first i'll give you an overview of
princess margaret living biobank
what who we are
and lessons learned from establishment
and propagation of tumor organoids and
also
to give you some
or show you some lessons that we learned
from drug screening of two organoids and
tell you a little bit about current and
future directions of the core
so
as as many of you uh have probably used
biobanks in the past
biobanks are by repositories that accept
uh that accept processes and stores and
distribute biospecimen and also
associated data
for use in research and clinical
care now historically biobanks have been
depositing mostly non-life tissue
that had limited applications living
biobanks on the other hand involve
biobanking of live tissues
either through cryopreservation
of tissues for later use or generation
of patient-derived models that could be
cryopreserved and renewed
so these living tissues can then be
applied in preclinical testing biomarker
discovery toxicity evaluation of
pharmaceutical agents
and also it can be used to drive
precision medicine approaches in
treatment of diseases
so
there's three types of patient-derived
models that have been used for
biobanking and
subsequently for research purposes these
are established cell lines from the
patient material a patient-derived
genograph models that are grown in mice
and also patient-derived organoids
now currently organoid models are
gaining a lot of traction in this field
because they closely mimic phenotype
benzene a type of original tissues
compared to cell lines for example
they're cheaper and faster to grow than
pbx models
they grow in large numbers so they're
amenable to large drug screening efforts
some disadvantages
include the fact that these models are
void of any cells from tumor
microenvironment
and we're still not sure how their
behavior mimics the clinical behavior
and also they're quite expensive to grow
now the living princess margaret living
biobank has been around for last five
years
and we established it in hopes to
consolidate
existing patient-derived models
and also to make new patient-derived
models
for effective distributions of resources
to research community
we also wanted to optimize model sharing
of models and data um
for our institute but also for other
academics and and different companies
so the way it works that we receive
tissues or fluids from biopsies or
surgeries of princess margaret cancer
patients that are diagnosed with various
types and you can see the types that we
are currently working with
in this figure
we generate
the patient-derived models and then
biobank them for future use
there are two arms of the facility one
arm led by dr nuenfem
generates in biobank xenograph models
while the other arm that's led by me
develops technology and generates
organoid models and biobanks them for
future use
so the focus of this talk will be on the
organoid core but i do encourage you to
check out um
like more of the collection of the
xenographs then you can also go on the
on our website too for more information
so who we are so we are again the living
biobank coordinate core and the way we
generated a score is we really
collaborated with our researchers
and the uh biospecimen biobank
that allows
generate specific
consenting processes and protocols to
generate these models and we are the
first uhn next generation biobanking
facility
we absolutely established the central
repository of patient-derived organwood
models develop soc and q a for pdo
generation and use and also we provide
these materials and services and models
for the use of pdos
to our own researchers but also external
academics
we support our
researchers
by providing these models and also we
try to
enhance the current quality of
publications and maximize the grant
awards
so
most of you are probably aware what
organoids are i'm going to quickly just
remind you
of what this technology is all about so
this was pioneered by dr hans cleaver's
group and it's based on 3d growth of
tumor or normal cells derived from adult
tissues
they can also be derived from embryonic
tissues or ips cells so this technology
have been developed over the last decade
and the protocols have been established
for generation of organoids from
different organ sites
and some of these are summarized here
now the technology involves
dissociation of cancer or normal tissue
from patients
and subsequent plating of these
dissociated cells in extracellular
matrix
such as
media containing tissue specific niche
factors that support the proliferation
and differentiation of organoids
and of course the different niche
factors are used to grow different types
of tissues
and you can also grow both normal and
cancer organized using this technique
but over the years this technology
allowed for generation and subsequent
biobanking of patient-derived cultures
and uses of these models range from
cancer modeling gene profiling drug
efficiency testing and regeneration
medicine
now the success rate of organ
regeneration varies across different
tumor types as well as across specimen
sources used to generate these models
and here are some numbers that have been
reported in the most recent review
article like leavers group
so first you can see that efficiency
varies from 100 to 15
however one of the issues that we have
run into as a biobank
is that when actually looking at this
data and applying it to our success
rates is how the term efficiency is
actually
defined so efficiency is still defined
differently across different
publications and groups
some groups define efficiency as
initiation rate or whether or not it's a
yes or no growth of organoids while
others define them as models that grow a
particular amount of time in the culture
in addition the quality assessment to
these publications is not standardized
and all of this might not be an issue
for a research group but is definitely
an issue for leaving biobank because we
want to make sure that the models that
we
have in the biobank are renewable they
can grow for long periods of time and
that they have predictable growth
patterns
so
we have quickly learned that reaching
some of these published organic
generation efficiencies have been quite
challenging and for the most part not
met
so while we start we'll already
establish technologies we have optimized
many protocols in the house
so i will a little bit about a workflow
um so basically
when we get the tissue from the patients
that are consented
we
record this in our tissue database we
de-identify the patient and we always
keep a little bit of a tissue to snap
freeze the tissue and also embed it for
histology the tissue is then processed
in our facility where we dissociate the
tissue embed that just embed the cells
in the matrigel and we establish the
optimal growth conditions for that
particular model
our goal is to establish long-term
cultures that we define as
models that grow for at least six to ten
passages
and there have
a predictable splitting ratio
and they can be renewable so once we
know that the organoid is going to make
it as a long-term culture we then do
extensive characterization that includes
genotype matching to the original tissue
histology
characterization which includes um using
different immunohemistic
immunohistochemistry markers that are
used to
diagnose the specific disease we prefer
mycoplasma testing doubling rate and
also flow analysis is sometimes
important particularly when making these
models from demographics and i'm going
to get get into that in a bit
and then we generally buy a bank about
10 cryovials per model and this is under
the patient parent distributed sample
and and and a lot of these
organoids also come with some clinical
some clinical data and then we document
sops for each of these models
so now i would like to uh get into into
some of our collection uh just to show
you uh have a brief overview of what
these models look like
so the colorectal organoid models we
have generated about 46 long-term models
uh success rate varies between 75 to 80
percent with 80 success rate
um of biobank models being the models
that are generated from xenograft
tissues
we have a variety of models from either
primary metastatic tissue
from xenograft tissue or from the normal
tissues
the maximum passage ratios for these
models is 1 to 16 and the minimum is 1
to 2.
and the medium splitting ratio it's
about one to seven
and these are some histo histology um
representatives though the histology
varies depending on um if it's a normal
a tumor organoid of course but the tumor
organoids are usually
small size gland forming epithelial
clusters
with either large or small lumens and
sometimes they have multiple lumens as
well most of these are ck20 positive and
this is not shown
here our next set of um and i would say
our biggest collection is uh from
organoids that are generated from
patients with pancreatic adenocarcinoma
or pdac
we have generated models from both
surgical tissues from
the biopsy or metastatic tissue sites
and from xenograft tissue our success
rate is from 50 to 80 percent with 50
being success rate of biobank samples
generated from biopsies and 80 from
xenografts
and challenging was to actually make the
models uh from biopsy simply because of
the
lymph of the small amount of material
that one really gets from biopsies
they grow out quite fast
usually the the average
uh the medium the average splitting
ratio is one to four
um
every
11 days
and this is the typical histology
again these are mostly clusters of cells
with thick epithelium and varied lumens
they have moderate to
high nuclear pleueomorphism they have
some mitotic events and also they're all
ck19 positive
our next set were lung organoids and we
have actually published a paper on this
they have been challenging to grow to
say the least we have um been growing
them from not for non-small cell
carcinoma patients and also from small
cell carcinoma patients
success rate varies from 10 to 50
percent our best success rate is growing
them from small cell lung cancer tissues
and from non-small cell
xenograft tissues
the biggest issues in growing these from
the primary resected
tissues is the normal outgrowth um that
has been documented in literature
uh and that definitely has been uh has
been a
has been one of the
issues um in the core
to generate
these models
but the passage rate uh
the the average fast and splitting ratio
is one to three and usually every every
10 to 10 days to 14 days
and here is also also we have a doubling
rate for these models generally the
doubling rate is about 58 hours
histology varies with the diagnosis so
adenocarcinoma
squamous uh small cell
carcinoma they're all have
sort of different uh histologies
um and
for
adenocarcinoma organoid models are
generally ttf1 positive where squamous
shows positivity for p63
and these are some of the representative
histologies
another set of models
esophageal organoids are from esophageal
adenocarcinoma we grown them from both
reflected tissues and biopsy tissues the
success rate is from 50 to 70
these models um grow pretty fast one to
four splitting ratio every 11 days and
the doubling rate is about 54.
average average doubling rate is about
50 for
54 hours
this is what some of these organized
models look like they're clusters of
cells
and they have varied lumens
so now the last two tumor types have
been very challenging so one of them was
ovarian
while majority of our
ovarian tissues will generate or
initiate organoids not many of them can
actually be biobanked because they sh
they grow only for a short period of
time we sort of indicate that the media
is not or the technology is you know not
adequate to grow these models
but the average and also they grow a bit
slower than the rest so the average
splitting ratio is about one to three
and they're they're
generally passaged every two to three
weeks
and the doubling rate um is also about
seven average 72 hours
so our highest success rate would
probably be from ascites fluid and of
course our lowest success rate would be
from the primary sector cases
biopsies are
super difficult we haven't really
been able to grow too many um
long-term organoid models from those
and the finally breast organoid models
again we have processed many tissues and
you use many different types of medias
um and
however
that that can be bio-banked
most of these organoids so the success
rate is low is 10 to 30 percent and most
of the ones that we actually made are
either high grade or triple negative
so the low grade are generally very
difficult to make
and number one issue
again you know if i was to show you
initiation rates you know it would
probably be anywhere between 90 to 100
most of these will grow something
however the major issue here is the
contamination of normal cells
and of the normal organoids
um so this is an important thing to
address
moving forward
um you know because it's important to
incorporate appropriate qcs when using
these models
in early
passages because if you want to use them
for drug screens you got to make sure
that whatever you're growing
is not of normal origin
so that is um sort of our collection and
i concluded here two slides to show you
some of these issues that we've faced
particularly on normal outgrowth uh on
breast and lung
uh when using breast and lung surgical
tissues so these normal organoids
um
are have certain characteristics that
are distinct that distinguish them from
two marginoids
for example in case of breast um their
basal and show ck5 positivity on the
edges of the organoids
in the case of the lung
they show positivity for p63 even when
grown from adenocarcinoma specimen which
are not supposed to be positive for
those markers um the organoids are very
uniform in size uh and there is short
and show no nuclei atifia
in addition based on our observations
these models are short-lived they can
only grow for up to 10 passages
they're hard to revive after freezing
and
it usually
what we do if histology hints that these
models could be normal we then use snip
analysis
to identify the origin of the organoid
for this we send the tumor
normal tissue and the organoid from the
same patient
and then we
this is and then we perform the snip
analysis so here's an example of two uh
so the first one turned out to be a
tumor organoid so this is uh all refers
to the cnv this is the cnb profile of
the organoid it matches to the
cnv profile of the tumor whereas the
other model organoid model you can
clearly see uh the cnb changes in the
tumor
that are and completely silent um
genotype as a genome
in in the normal or in the normal
organoids
so again very important to utilize qc
methods in your research if you're using
um
using models organoid models for breast
and lung
because um especially if you drug
screening then you want to make sure
that what you're growing
are the tumor organoids
another thing that we have encountered
uh
or that is
when we grow organoids from xenograft
tissues
uh
sometimes we'll get mouse organ with
contamination and they kind of look
quite interesting um so here is an
example of a breast organoid that's
derived from xenograft tissue so as you
can see here there seem to be two
populations of organoids that are
apparent here
small organoids and really large dark
organoids so these large dark structures
are actually mouth cells
and if you're not properly handling them
they will take over the entire cultures
and you might end up working with mouth
cells without without knowing
so we have incorporated a qc step when
processing xenograft tissue
and so we use h2k antibody depletion so
this way we deplete mouth cells
after dissociation so in hoping hoping
to enrich for uh the tumor cells um that
are actually being plated for major for
generation
while this has improved our success rate
there are still many cultures that have
a large proportion of mouth organized
that just like to grow
and so if working with such cultures one
should periodically perform flow
analysis to confirm
that you are indeed working with human
tumor organoids and not mass
so again if using these four drug
screens this qc step uh seems to be
necessary
so these are the lessons that we have
learned
basically we
we need to establish the clear criteria
for organization establishment
definitions
what is initiation what are short-term
what are long-term cultures
we try to address um the normal
outgrowths and and perform proper qc
to identify it um
insufficient starting material is always
a problem if you don't have enough tumor
cells it's very difficult to initiate
these organoids
mouse contamination should be addressed
and you know continuously improve the
organ with technology whether or not
it's by
using multiple medias consider
because we need to consider
heterogeneity of these tissues
using alternative to matrigel and also
find ways to eliminate the normal
outgrowth
so
let's now look at the ways we utilize
these models for different projects and
we work with many principal
investigators at uhn
external academics and for-profit
companies on projects they utilize these
models
uh for instance for drug screening
efforts what i will highlight here are
some results from already published
papers
so our first one of the first papers we
published was with dr ming chau's group
at uhn so we published a paper on
generating organoids from non-small cell
lung cancer tissues
so our technology allowed um had sort of
a success varying success rate from zero
percent for primary squamous tissues to
about 30 percent from lung
adenocarcinoma xenograft tissues
we have also utilized some short-term
cultures for drug screens
and in one of our experiments we
assessed the correlation of drug
response between organoid and parallel
xenograph models so this is the second
um
this is the set of graphs that you can
see here so basically uh the organoid
screen revealed sensitivity of k-ras
mutant models to mac inhibitor
tremendous compared to keras wild-type
models so the k-ras model is the orange
orange line here
and the same experiment was then
performed in nievo and the results also
revealed differential responses of krs
wild type and krs mutant xenograph
models to tramatinib
um our other paper that we have
collaborated on
collaborated with dr gail darling and dr
jonathan young from year 10
is to generate and screen organoid
models generated from patients with
esophageal adenocarcinoma
so the establishment rates here was
about
57.2 percent
um and
we published the characterization of
five models
these models were drug tested and
and characterized
so um
so the primary if you can look at the
histology pictures here uh the primary
tumor in all five um endoscopic biopsies
showed a spectrum of
morphological features ranging from
well-formed glands to creepy form nests
to sheets of cells
then also demonstrating this presence of
heterogeneity
and overall the organoids that were
derived from these tissues recapitulated
the cytological features of these
biopsies
whole exome sequencing sequencing was
also performed and it revealed similar
mutations
of
eac driver genes in organoid tissue
pairs
organoids were then treated with single
chemotherapy agent each of which are
part of a clinic clinically utilized in
induction regimen
and overall the organoids displayed
various sensitivities to different drugs
which kind of suggests an individualized
response to each chemotherapy reagent
in this case we did not have um there
was a first paper it was a small set we
had no corresponding patient data but
currently we're working with the team on
a bigger set and that sort of is the
publication that's in the pipeline and
that publication will
more directly address the correlation of
organ or drug response to the
the patient response
and another one this is the most recent
paper we have published so this
is
on generation of xenograft and organoid
models from resected pancreatic duodenal
and biliary cancers
so we focused on efforts on generating
organoids from pancreatic adenocarcinoma
xenografts here
and these are some of the representative
models these models are actually a rare
k-ras wild-type models of
patriotic asthma carcinoma
one of these models was osip 256 and
this was shown to have an oncogenic
in-frame the raf deletion mutation
and current clinical trials are sort of
underway to test a possible inhibitor
for this bref mutation that's a lie 309
120 inhibitor and we actually tested
efficacy of this inhibitor in both in
vitro and in vivo model of oc 256
patients
or absence of mac inhibitor traumatip so
you can see here in both of these graphs
for in vitro uh the lie 300 alone
showed minimum efficacy on organoid uh
growth that was
also shown in vivo however the
combination of
lye and termetinib showed better
efficiency efficacy in both organoid and
xenograph model
so another thing that we have discovered
as working on this project is that
organoid models can actually be
generated from properly cryopreserved
tissues
so we have uh we had a big biobank of
these uh tissues that were cryopreserved
and and majority of the models were
actually made
from cryopreserved tissues
and again also
these this
this data also says that you know if if
there are many genographs already
available it's useful to actually
generate these organoids from these
models because they're better used for
the first line discovery um and and you
know such as
larger drug screen panels and you know
you can always do a confirmation
of the response in vivo
and also majority of the organoid models
that we have generated can actually be
grafted and that's another another good
test
for um to assess whether or not the or
the organoid is actually a tumorogenic
so those are those are our results and
the lessons of course we learned from
these drug screens is that
um you know if uh if you're screening
the long-term organoid models you
actually get consistent results across
technical and experimental replicates
and across different passages because
you can predict how the model grows and
there's some correlation with within
vivo response the screening of
short-term models can again
you have to be careful with these
because there you have to include a lot
of qc steps here
uh for instance you might have to enrich
for epithelial content by using sorting
you might have to include doubling rate
controls um
to make sure that your organoids are
actually doubling at the time during the
drug screening period
uh also tumor purity controls are
important such as histology and snip
analysis to make sure that you're not
drug testing muscle cells or normal
cells and also
you know it's also good to culture them
for a few passages before drugging if
possible at all
so our future directions are in
improving our organoid establishment
rates across different tumor types
also we are working with many teams at
uhn to generate complex models including
cancer stroma and immune cells
and also working with clinical
translational clinical teams to actually
get some more
idea of how correlated organoid response
is to actual patient drug response
and um to sort of finish this off um
you know we have we have worked with
many uhn uh
researchers but we can also work with
many different academics and uh
um different for-profit companies
we can distribute models we can also um
work with with you on the drug screening
projects we also do quality assessments
of existing organoids and there are many
custom projects that are that are
happening in our facility
we have worked with
with number of collaborators shown here
and our list is growing
every day i said we have been around for
five years
but really our collection has
has increased in the last few years
um this is these are the acknowledgments
uh and you know i i will finish sort of
by acknowledging many of our staff from
both organoid and pdx cores and many
talented people here
uh also our pi collaborators um that
have been a key in helping us develop
technologies to grow these models
we really have um have them as our
advisors and we have been
you know getting grants with these pis
and and publishing along along along
with them
um also the careful modal
characterization is something we are
particularly proud of in the core
and this would not be possible without
many other cores in our institutes
including genomic course
bioinformatics course
profiling labs in uh biospecimen
biobanks
and that's it
thank you thank you for your attention